hi I'm back and we're gonna talk about
vitamin k2 and something called
pathological calcification okay now what
is pathological calcification this is a
condition in your body where calcium is
developing in the wrong places it's
usually involved in plaquing in the
arteries it could also be the
calcification of part of your stomach
kidney as in kidney stones or even
calcification in Pawleys cystic kidney
disease it could also be calcification
in your lungs
there's calcification in the breast
tissue calcification of the cornea of
the eye so it's calcium deposits
involved in certain disease states now
there's a lot more to know about this
condition but I just wanted to give you
some of the basics so we have this
calcium that is developing in the soft
tissues of the body not in the bone this
calcium could be developing as a need to
act like a band-aid because there's
oxidation in the vascular system or a
certain part of the body and let's say
you don't have enough vitamin E to
protect that oxidative lesion or
selenium which is a very powerful
antioxidant involved with glutathione
which is the main antioxidant of the
liver then you have the added ischemia
which is a lack of blood flow that
combination of low nutrients damage to
the tissues low blood flow calcium will
tend to invade and start to actually
heal the area at the expense of clogging
an artery now the other interesting
thing about this is calcium will tend to
accumulate in certain parts of the body
and involving the control of pH like the
kidneys like this stomach so the stomach
makes hydrochloric acid and if you're
not making enough hydrochloric acid and
that stomach tissue becomes a little too
alkaline you'll have calcium deposits
because of that then you have nano
bacteria which is the smallest known
bacteria they're very tiny and you have
these little microbes that hide in these
little calcium shells or a little egg
loose to protect themselves as a
survival mechanism
almost impossible to kill with
antibiotics and they're involved in so
many diseases that have calcification
connected to it like periodontal disease
or calcification the arteries or even
kidney stones
sometimes gall stones and just as a side
note if you suspect a nano bacteria
because you have calcification in any of
these locations I would recommend taking
folic acid and something called EDTA
this is the natural key later now let me
just shift gears to vitamin k2 vitamin
k1 has everything to do with clotting
okay preventing bleeding vitamin k2 is
completely different it's involved in
about 17 different proteins involving
the movement of calcium out of the soft
tissue back into the bone out of the
soft tissue into the teeth for example
now there are other functions too for
example one being involved in the
mitochondria and this is one of the
reasons why if they have enough vitamin
k2 they have a lot of energy I
personally notice when I take vitamin k2
I'm much stronger when I work out so it
has a lot to do with building up the
mitochondria especially with skeletal
muscle and providing endurance so
vitamin k2 has about stopping some type
of bleeding going on the body vitamin k2
is the transportation of calcium and
then comes up the question is vitamin k2
a common vitamin deficiency and the
answer is yes absolutely many people are
deficient in vitamin k2 and it could be
for various reasons but vitamin k2 is in
organ meats it's an egg yolks it's in
butter it's in hard cheeses it's in
goose liver so if you're in a low-fat
diet you may be deficient now it's also
in fermented soybeans for example
there's a product called NATO but in
America very few people consume
fermented soybeans as NATO unless you
live in Japan you're probably not going
to consume that on a regular basis but
if you did you would get vitamin k2 now
you could take it from a supplement and
get vitamin k2 very easily but I just
wanted to point out
it was discovered in 1994 that if you're
deficient the body will convert to
vitamin k2 and in 1998 it was discovered
that vitamin k1 could convert to vitamin
k2 without the bacteria like in your
flora because your microbes make
vitamins definitely vitamin k1
but even without this bacteria you can
actually make some k2
now here's the problem what if you're
also deficient in vitamin k1 what are
the common vitamin k1 foods the leafy
greens so for those people who don't
consume enough greens or foods that have
k2 they are going to be deficient now I
also want to mention that antibiotics
will deplete vitamin k2 a low-fat diet
could be the reason why you have a low
vitamin k2 of course if you're not
consuming the fermented soy nado if
you're on statins that could be the
reason why you have low vitamin k2
mineral oil will deplete vitamin k2 GI
tract issues irritable bowel syndrome
celiac can cause malabsorption and lower
your k2 and if you have liver damage
let's say you have a fatty liver that
could also be the reason why you have
low vitamin k2 and there's another
important point that's quite interesting
professor Bruce Ames developed something
called a triage theory and that theory
goes like this if you the subclinical
vitamin deficiency and let's say you
have some of the vitamin but you don't
have the full required amount the body
will then ration out what it has only
for those actions involving short-term
survival and it will not allocate that
nutrient for all of the functions that
don't involve short-term survival so
when we talk about vitamin k1 and let's
say you had a subclinical deficiency of
vitamin k1 which means you didn't have
enough of it the body's going to
allocate that to coagulation first which
is going to involve the stopping of any
type of broken blood vessels or bleeding
internally before any is Alec
to the calcium removal and I really
think this right here is the reason why
so many people have calcium building up
in the wrong place simply because they
either don't have enough vitamin k1 to
convert to k2 or they're not consuming
enough of the k2 or they're on
antibiotics or they might be in statins
or they have digestive issues or a fatty
liver those are the more common reasons
why we have this problem it can also be
a low vitamin E combined with adding a
lot of sugar to your diet and high carbs
which create the oxidation in the first
place which then can even make you
susceptible to certain types of bacteria
which make things worse so in summary if
you have calcification what you need to
do is take some of this some of this
right here make sure you start taking
vitamin k2 because if you're trying to
get this from food probably is not going
to be enough you want to take larger
quantities to start actually reversing
some of this damage right here and I
would definitely start beefing up no pun
intended vitamin k1 by consuming more
leafy greens and if you don't have any
symptoms of any type of calcium buildup
as a preventative measure I would do
healthy Kido which is large amounts of
greens healthy fats to get your k2 and
your gonna be totally bulletproof thanks
for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications